♫
>> Tucker: WELL, GOOD
EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
YOU MAY THINK THE MEDIA ARE
ONLY CAPABLE OF SKEPTICISM
AND LOATHE SOME.
JOURNALISTS CAN LOVE TOO.
LATEST CRUSH THE DEMOCRATIC
PEOPLE’S REPUBLIC OF NORTH
KOREA.
KIM YO JONG IS AT THE WINTER
OLYMPICS THIS WEEK.
ACCORDING TO THE PRESS, SHE
IS A HUGE STAR.
BIGGER STAR EVEN THAN OUR
VICE PRESIDENT, MIKE PENCE
OR FOR THAT MATTER BIGGER
THAT ARE STAN ANY OF THE
ACTUAL ATHLETES.
DON’T BELIEVE IT, CONSIDER
SOME OF THESE DESCRIPTIONS
FROM "THE WASHINGTON POST:
THE IVANKA TRUMP OF NORTH
KOREA CAPTIVATES.
FROM CNN, SHE IS STEALING
THE SHOW.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" SAYS
SHE TURNS ON THE CHARM.
REUTERS, THE NEWS WIRE,
MEANWHILE, WRITES THIS,
QUOTE:  NORTH KOREA HAS
EMERGED AS THE EARLY
FAVORITE TO GRAB ONE OF THE
WINTER OLYMPIC’S MOST
IMPORTANT MEDALS, THE
DIPLOMATIC GOLD.
UGH.
THE REPORTERS GUSHED OVER
THE LAST TOTALITARIAN STATE
MIKE PENCE WHO AGAIN IS THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES ATTACKED FOR NOT
STANDING UP TO HONOR NORTH
KOREAN ATHLETES, WATCH.
>> MY THOUGHT WAS THAT MIKE
PENCE SAID IT WAS
INAPPROPRIATE TO MAKE
POLITICAL STATEMENTS AT
SPORTING EVENTS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> IF YOU ARE IN KOREA, YOU
NEED TO STAND UP.
YOU NEED TO STAND UP AND
SHOW RESPECT.
THE OLYMPICS ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE THE ONE PLACE WHERE
POLITICS IS NOT SUPPOSED TO
PLAY A PART.
THAT’S MY UNDERSTANDING.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE
SURPRISED, YOU SHOULDN’T BE,
PROGRESSIVES HAVE A LONG AND
DISHONORABLE HISTORY OF
SUPPORTING THE WORLD’S MOST
REPRESSIVE REGIMES.
NO SURPRISE.
"NEW YORK TIMES" SUPPORTED
JOSEPH STALIN EVEN AS HE WAS
MURDERING UP TO 12 MILLION
UKRAINIANS IN THE FAMOUS
FAMINE THERE.
THAT PAPER LED THE CHEERING
FOR FIDEL CASTRO AS HE
TURNED CUBA INTO A POLICE
STATE.
IN 1975, WE’RE NOT MAKING
THIS UP.
WHEN THE SWEPT TO TOWER IN
CAM BODY I CAN’T.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" MADE
THIS PREDICTION IN A
HEADLINE, QUOTE:  FOR MOST,
A BETTER LIFE.
ONE OF THE WORST GENERAL
SIDES IN HISTORY FOLLOWED
SHORTLY THEREAFTER.
TURNED OUT NOT TO BE TRUE.
IT’S HARD TO FIND A DICTATOR
THE LEFT HAS NOT SUPPORTED.
CHAIRMAN MAO, HUGO CHAVEZ,
THEY ALL HATE AMERICA.
PROGRESSIVE ACTIVISTS ALSO
HAVE ONE THING IN COMMON
THEY RESENT THEIR FATHERS.
THAT’S WHERE THEIR POLITICS
COME FROM.
THE REST ARE JUST WINDOW
DRESSING.
A WEEKLY COMMUNIST NEWSPAPER
THAT SUPPORTS THE NORTH
KOREA REGIME WHERE SHE HAS
VISITED SHE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
DEIDRE, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
YOU ARE A LONG TIME
COMMUNIST.
LONG TIME SUPPORTER OF THE
DPRK.
YOU VISITED AT THE
INVITATION OF THE
GOVERNMENT.
YOU THINK ITS LEADERS ARE
GREAT.
WHEN YOU SEE CNN AND REUTERS
AGREEING WITH YOU THAT ITS
LEADERS ARE GREAT, THAT MUST
VALIDATE YOU?
I MEAN, YOU MUST CHEER AS
YOU WATCH THE OLYMPIC
COVERAGE.
>> I HAVE BEEN TO BOTH NORTH
KOREA AND SOUTH KOREA AND
I’M ON THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE
I WANTS TO TALK TO THE
PEOPLE WHO WATCH YOUR SHOW
AND MAKE A SERIOUS POINT
THAT WE’RE IN THE PROCESS OF
MOVING TOWARDS A NUCLEAR
WAR.
AND THEY HAVE NEVER
EXPERIENCED THAT BUT THE
KOREAN PEOPLE KNOW VERY MUCH
WHAT WAR IS LIKE AND THEY
ARE NOT FOR IT.
AND THE PEOPLE OF SOUTH
KOREA DON’T WANT WAR ANY
MORE THAN THE PEOPLE OF
NORTH KOREA DO.
AND THEY SHOWED THAT AT THE
OLYMPICS, IN THE OPENING
CEREMONIES WHEN THEY CHEERED
WITH GREAT JOY THE FACT THAT
THE NORTH AND THE SOUTH WERE
MARCHING TOGETHER.
>> Tucker: SO SINCE HAVE YOU
BEEN TO BOTH COUNTRIES I’M
WONDERING.
ONE IS THE LAST STALL INIST
REGIME.
PRETTY RIGIDLY MARKIST.
SOUTH KOREA IS FLOOREDLY
CAPITALIST.
MARKET BASED ECONOMY WHICH,
OF COURSE, YOU REJECT.
WHICH COUNTRY WOULD YOU
RATHER LIVE IN PERSONALLY?
>> I WON’T TRY TO ANSWER,
DEBATE YOU ON EVERYTHING
HAVE YOU SAID.
>> Tucker: NOT DEBATING YOU.
>> YOU GOT THE WHOLE HOUR.
I ONLY HAVE A COUPLE OF
MINUTES.
BUT WHAT I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT.
>> Tucker: YOU’RE NOT GOING
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION?
>> WHAT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
IS WHAT I THINK IS REALLY AN
IMPORTANCE TO THE PEOPLE OF
THIS COUNTRY.
THAT IS THAT THERE IS A
GROUP IN WASHINGTON THAT
REALLY WANTS TO PUSH FOR A
WAR.
THE KOREAN PEOPLE DON’T WANT
IT.
PEOPLE HERE DON’T WANT A
WAR.
BUT THEY DON’T KNOW WHAT A
WAR IS LIKE.
THEY THINK YOU JUST PUSH A
BUTTON SOMEWHERE.
THAT’S NOT TRUE.
>> Tucker: I HAVE NEVER SAID
THIS TO A COMMUNIST BEFORE
BUT I ACTUALLY AGREE WITH
YOU.
I DON’T WANT A WAR IN KOREA.
>> GOOD.
>> Tucker: I THINK THERE ARE
PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON WHO ARE
PUSHING FOR IT I THINK YOU
ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THERE.
WHERE I DISAGREE WITH YOU WE
DON’T KNOW WHAT THE PEOPLE
OF NORTH KOREA WANT BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO SAY
WHAT THEY WANT.
>> THAT’S BOLOGNA.
TUCKER TUCK DO THEY HAVE
INTERNET ACCESS THERE?
OH, THEY DON’T.
>> THEY KNOW WHAT’S GOING ON
IN THE WORLD.
THEY KNOW PERFECTLY WELL
THAT’S GOING ON IN THE
WORLD?
KNOW?
IT’S ILLEGAL TO WATCH A
FOREIGN MOVIE THERE.
>> YOU ARE MAKING UP A LOT
OF STUFF.
>> Tucker: IS THAT NOT TRUE.
>> PEOPLE OF NORTH KOREA
VERY AWARE OF WHAT IS GOING
ON IN THE WORLD.
NORTH KOREA HAS A
100 PERCENT LITERACY RATE.
DID YOU KNOW THAT?
>> Tucker: I DID, YEAH.
>> I GOT THAT FIGURE FROM
THE CIA FACT BOOK IF YOU
WANTS TO CHECK IT OUT.
THEY HAVE UNIVERSAL MEDICAL
CARE.
THEY ARE NOT IN SOME KIND OF
A, YOU KNOW, JAIL.
THEY ARE NOT.
THEY ARE.
>> Tucker: REALLY?
>> THEY ARE PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO GET OUT FROM UNDERNEATH
THE THREAT OF WAR THAT THE
U.S. HAS POSED EVER SINCE IT
INVADED THEIR COUNTRY IN
196 -- I KNOW YOU DON’T WANT
TO DEBATE.
I’M ASSUME YOU DON’T WANT TO
ANSWER REAL QUESTIONS.
LET’S TRY A COUPLE OF THEM.
IF THEY ARE FREE, WHY CAN’T
THEY LEAVE?
>> LOOK, PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: THAT’S A FAIR
QUESTION.
>> PEOPLE GO BACK AND FORTH.
YOU KNOW, YOU ARE TAKING
THIS WHOLE -- IN A WHOLE
OTHER DIRECTION THAT
SHOULDN’T BE OF ANY
SIGNIFICANCE TO PEOPLE HERE.
>> Tucker: WAIT, WHY DOES IT
LOOK -- YOU ARE UP HERE
SPEAKING, HOLD ON.
>> PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON WHO
ARE FOR A WAR.
WHY DO YOU THINK THEY ARE
FOR A WAR?
>> Tucker: THAT’S ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAVEN’T BEEN
ABLE TO ANSWER FOR 35 YEARS
HERE.
ONE QUESTION I HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO ANSWER SIMPLY IS
THIS NORTH KOREA A FREE
PLACE A PLACE YOU WOULD WANT
TO LIVE OR IS IT A PRISON?
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
IMPRISONMENT 800 PER
100,000.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS IN
SOUTH KOREA 100.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
IMPRISONMENT RATE IS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: IT’S VERY HIGH
NOWHERE NEAR 800.
>> GREATER THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
>> Tucker: THAT’S NOT TRUE.
NORTH KOREA IS THE HIGHEST.
>> NO, NO, NO.
I’M TALKING ABOUT THE NUMBER
OF PRISONERS HIGHEST IN THE
WORLD IN THE UNITED STATES.
THAT’S TRUE.
AND THE MAJORITY OF THEM ARE
POOR PEOPLE, AND THEY
WOULDN’T BE IN JAIL IF THEY
HAD A LAWYER TO KEEP THEM
OUT OF JAIL.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON HAVE
LAWYERS.
KEEP THEM OUT OF JAIL.
>> Tucker: THIS IS THE POINT
I WAS MAKING.
IS THAT NO REGIME, NO MATTER
HOW REPRESSIVE, HOW MANY OF
ITS OWN PEOPLE HAD HAS
KILLED, IS EVER UNDEFENDED
BY THE LEFT IF IT HATES
AMERICA.
IF NORTH KOREA SUDDENLY
BECAME PRO-AMERICAN, YOU
WOULDN’T SUPPORT IT, WOULD
YOU?
YOU KNOW THAT YOU WOULDN’T.
>> YOU SAY THAT THIS IS A
COUNTRY THAT HATES AMERICA.
>> Tucker: I WOULD SAY THAT
OF NORTH KOREA.
I THINK THAT’S FIRE SAY.
GOING OUT ON A LIMB THERE,
YES, I AM.
>> COME OVER TO THIS COUNTRY
AND BOMB US?
IF THEY EVER DO WHAT THE
U.S. DID TO KOREA, DO YOU
THINK THE KOREANS FEEL GOOD
ABOUT WHAT THE U.S. DID TO
KOREA?
THE U.S. BOMBED EVERY
BUILDING OVER ONE STORY
DURING THE KOREAN WAR.
BOMBERS HAD TO COME BACK
WITH THEIR PAY LOADS
UNDROPPED BECAUSE THERE WERE
NO BUILDINGS LEFT TO BOMB.
>> Tucker: JUST A QUICK
REALITY CHECK DO YOU EVER
SAY TO YOURSELF YOU KNOW, I
DISLIKE AMERICA WHERE I
LIVE.
>> I DON’T DISLIKE.
>> Tucker: MORE THAN I
DISLIKE NORTH KOREA.
>> I I DON’T DISLIKE THE
PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY AS
WELL.
I’M THINKING ABOUT THEM AS
WELL AS THE PEOPLE OF NORTH
KOREA A WE SHOULD NOT HAVE A
WAR AGAINST NORTH KOREA.
>> Tucker: I’M WITH YOU
THERE.
>> THE PENTAGON WHO ARE
ACTUALLY DOING THE PLANNING
FOR SUCH WAR?
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU
SUCH QUESTION --
>> -- YOU KNOW THERE IS
GOING TO BE WAR GAMES COMING
UP NORTH KOREA.
>> Tucker: I DON’T WANT TO
HAVE TO CUT YOU OFF.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ONE LAST
QUESTION A SINCERE ONE.
>> WE HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
>> Tucker: I GOT IT DOES IT
BOTHER YOU AT ALL.
RETHINK YOUR DEFENSE OF
NORTH KOREA WHEN YOU SEE ITS
POPULATION STARVING AND
LEADER DYING OF OBESITY?
>> THE PEOPLE THERE ARE NOT
STARVING.
>> Tucker: THEY JUST HAD A
FAMINE.
>> THIS IS A RUN IT THAT I
WAS LEFT IN ASHES, IN ASHES.
>> Tucker: IT’S OUR FAULT.
>> JUST A GENERATION AND A
HALF AGO.
THEY REBUILT THEIR COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE REBUILT THEIR
COUNTRY:  THEY HAVE, YOU
KNOW, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
KOREANS, THEY’RE THE
HEALTHIEST LOOKING PEOPLE IN
THE WORLD.
>> Tucker: THEY’RE THE BEST
EXCEPT FOR THE TAPE WORMS
AND TUBERCULOSIS.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU SHOULD GET SOME DENTAL
WORK.
>> YOU ARE TELLING PEOPLE
LIES ABOUT THE WORLD.
AND THAT’S WHAT YOUR STATION
DOES.
AND I AM NOT SURPRISED BY